let's talk trump's brilliant Secretary
of Education Betsy DeVos I love her
she's fun bubbly and she gets the job
done
like human wine spritzer Betsy is a
visionary in the field of education and
was the first and only cabinet member to
suggest that schools needed guns to
prevent grizzly bear attacks you laugh
but I had to pull my kids out of school
when I realized their social studies
teacher was a grizzly bear
it's the salmon Brett that gave him away
now Betsy is the best that's why I was
disgusted to see the mainstream media
whip out their claws and try to tear her
down Education Secretary Betsy DeVos was
featured on 60 minutes last night where
she seemed to struggle her interview
last night on 60 minutes was very rough
she gave a performance it has not
received stellar reviews ok stellar
reviews she got some bad reviews
whatever
just like my all-male rebuttal to the
Vagina Monologues all right yeah
[Applause]
people can be mean you move on what
really pisses me off is this gotcha
journalism that's 60 minutes employees
if you're not familiar 60 minutes is a
hidden camera prank show where lesley
stahl there Ashton Kutcher ambushes
unsuspecting interviewees with a series
of meticulously research questions
listen to Stahl go for the jugular why
have you become people say the most
hated cabinet secretary I'm not so sure
how exactly that happened but I think
there are a lot of really powerful
forces allied against change it does it
hurt sometimes it does sometimes it does
again I think I think I'm more
misunderstood than anything yes exactly
she's misunderstood like Dave Matthews
lyrics or anything Matt Damon says about
women there are powerful forces out
there working against a boss like the
results of things she's done in the past
now people think that just because she
ruled back protections on student loans
that she doesn't like students or that
because she's shifting money from public
schools to private religious and charter
schools that she doesn't like public
education wrong she wants public schools
to thrive that's why she's challenging
them with every conceivable obstacle
it's the same reason I hired that
grizzly bear to come to termite kids at
home
but now here comes lesley stahl totally
ambushing betsy with basic questions
about her job look do you think that
teachers should have guns in the
classroom that should be an option for
states and communities to consider and I
hesitate to think of like my first grade
teacher mrs. or Hoff I couldn't ever
imagine her having a gun and being
trained in that way damn it Betsy don't
bring up an example that totally
undercuts your entire argument what
about your second grade teacher mrs.
reinholt
that cold-blooded ice queen could drop a
gazelle at 200 yards
look the boss is obviously an expert on
schools and she must know everything
about public schools or she would have
spent some time in them have you seen
the really bad schools maybe try to
figure out what what they're doing I
have not I have not I've not
intentionally visited schools that are
underperforming maybe you should maybe I
should
this is worse than I thought
Lesley Stahl isn't just an ambush
journalist she's using Jedi Mind Tricks
maybe you should go to the schools yes
maybe I should go to the school it's a
trap Betsy the only good time to just
repeat something back is when you're
chanting at a rally or blindly going
along with the marriage that's it
this interview is obviously a massive
failure it's chaotic it's falling apart
and nobody wants to be there it's the
public school of interviews and Betsy
knows that the best way to fix a public
school is to not fix it and get the hell
out of there
[Music]